what I want to do is just take a step
back for a second and remember this
should have been fun right the tile of
method 5 was to remember only credit
barn very good credit borrowing which
included ideas like annuities and
electronic video but it's referring to
that these two groups of people or the
relationship between them credited are
people who load by dollars and debt is
other people crew forest right so you
can call me lenders and borrowers if you
like now one of the key ideas underneath
this whole topic which it took me years
to understand like even if I started
earning money I didn't really think this
through which is that creditors and
borrowers it's been literally two sides
the same coin sometimes you're wanted
sometimes you're the other now we've
been thinking at present if future value
very reasonable right present values and
future homes and we've been looking at
both them through the lens of you're an
investor you've got superannuation
you're the one putting money in what
will it be in the future if you put in a
thousand dollars every year
what is that equivalent to right now as
a compound interest low in the present
day if you wanted the same amount at the
end president future values we've been
thinking about from the point of view of
being lenders and putting money into a
bank and saying hey I'm letting you my
money right now what are you going to
pay me as a benefit but these same
concepts because these two money these
two sides of the same coin these same
concepts equally apply to borrowing
money which is why when we can learn
repayments today okay so in future years
what we're looking at the same content
it just takes a little extra thought
which I was going to guide you through
so I just started down the essential
details from question one we'll talk
through it for borrowers this amount of
money to buy a home unit is pretty funny
how quickly that number gets out of date
but anyway you can't buy something
the interest rate is 4.8% pirata
they say it compounds modulating and
increases to repeat low over this amount
of time okay
I'll calculate the monthly repayment
that's the first question
so the most thing we need to do is
notice that the information they've
given us from the interest rate and the
amount of time but it's not in the
format we need them for to answer this
question what's wrong with them they
need to Berkeley and currently they are
per annum and is okay so the first thing
you do is convert both of them 4.8% per
atom we want to work out what is that
equivalent to and the percentage per
what so we do there is very simple okay
so if you divide this by 12 for months
right you're going to get zero point
four percent which as a decimal is zero
point zero zero yes for yes
so the your calculator should be telling
you zero point zero zero four if you put
in four point eight percent divided by
12 no so if you put in four point eight
which you can't data and you didn't type
in the % as you divide that by twelve
you'll get zero point four right and
that's a better percentage but if you
type these four point eight percent the
percentage divided by 100 which is why
you can see the difference in on is that
again so this is the percentage and this
is the decimal okay so far so good
I need to do the same kind of thing
after this now very much you multiplied
you're multiplying the top with their
moments and that gives you two hundred
point okay so far so good now watching
portion a little bit and think this bits
tricky the hard time is not the button
mashing in the multiplying of the adding
all that the hard times are thinking and
working out what tools should you use
you're all these tools you to well now
what do I want to have
okay now thanks for a moment there are
monthly repayment so even putting money
in is doing it repeatedly
so therefore which of these do you think
is the most suitable option if he is
taking money and regularly depositing
them which of these makes sense
future value makes sense because
remember future values are taking some
annuity right and then doing it over and
over again during it and then you end up
at some set point okay so just keep that
in mind for a second future value
209,000 is what you pay off right so on
the face of it it would make sense to
say what is the amount is going to pay
every month actually should one monthly
repayment so it's functioning like an
annuity such that it gets to two hundred
and ninety thousand dollars that seems
reasonable except for a teeny little
problems and this is where we have to
wrestle with the difference between
these two things when you are looking at
it from different angles okay
while form is making his repayments
right each payment he makes the future
value grows because it can get interest
and it was more more positive that's
fine okay but what his repayments are
growing there's something else that's
growing as well namely it means that
definitely times like so it's almost
like a tug of war between the bank which
surely says hey no meanness and this is
going to get interest versus faltering
payments which are also going in and
they also need dangerous okay
so therefore the buckling repentance
they will not total to this right
they'll talk to a much larger sum what
are they going to told you
I will know it it's in the treaty idea
if I got to choose where the first time
we can work on movie attract children
made and olives write it in pages of
over 20 years because they're constantly
charging the interest throughout that
time by the end he will have pay off a
lot more than 200 knowing that not that
makes sense
suddenly right because he paid it up
this second he pay off that but in if
you end up next year it would have
certain interest at night he's opting up
next you he's paying off in two decades
okay so what I need to work out is well
what will that much larger amount we're
not going to be equivalent to so that's
just pop an interest on a equals P and
then one plus R to the N the large
amount that his loan is going to end up
with is going to be two hundred and
ninety thousand dollars they're ready
and then I'm going to operate on this
monthly compounding fee right so I'm
going to have 1 plus we already worked
out what the monthly interest rate is
going to be it's different D renewable
and how many times doesn't gain anything
okay now go rich you calculate up you're
going to get number out of this and
quite large I want it 755 and some
senses 10.30 it's right okay just just
pause before we progress any further
captives big that number is more than
double what he's actually borrowing
right the third this is totally gonna
case you very fine city just so um this
is B this is B but that's what happens
the longer you wait the more this stuff
is going to end up in fact really
quickly if you still got that in your
display just suppose you want to pay up
over 30 s my mortgage is a 30-year
mortgage tried to pay off Bartha how
would I change this the interest rate is
going to say what will change
the number of months will change right
30 years is 30 times 12 months that's
360 just quickly if it's still in your
calculator
go ahead gravity the change change out
to 360 once again 1 million two hundred
and twenty thousand dollars right which
you what's that that's like four times
four times the amount that he borrows
yes no it no it is significant
okay so the first answer to it is holy
cow that numbers me now this is what's
the monthly payments has to cover and
now your future now you think makes
sense now your future value has to do
this and now you're going to repeat that
the actual debt you're going to end up
hanging on to Twitter please okay
so I'm going to pay the monthly members
must pay off this total okay